I come from Bali, a very small
island in Indonesia.
The island is mostly known
around the world
as a very popular tourist destination,
with its beautiful landscapes,
clear blue beaches,
and most importantly,
its very unique culture and tradition.
Every single year in Bali,
we celebrate the Balinese New Year,
also known as Nyepi.
It is a day of silence
for the Balinese people;
no one is allowed to leave their houses,
no one is allowed to light any fire,
or use any devices
that are emitting light,
including television and lamps.
During the day it would be very quiet
and peaceful;
there'd be no more sounds of cars
or motorbikes passing by.
At night it would be pitch black,
complete darkness.
There would be no form of lights,
not even the light of the moon
since it’s also during the lunar eclipse.
Now, as a very young child,
I’ve always been terrified of the dark,
and I couldn’t bear the thought
that I had to go through these same nights
every single year.
I’ve always thought that we were alone,
that we were the only people in the world
still living like cavemen.
But the older I got,
the more I realized that one day in a year
without light is not so bad after all.
I realized that I was in fact not alone,
and that there are over a billion people
around the world
who are going through
these same nights that I feared
every single day of their lives.
I’ve grown to appreciate this tradition
and see it not only as a simple holiday,
but as a reminder to me that there are
people out there living without light
and that we should
do our best to help them.
I’ve experienced a day
of what it felt like
for those 1.2 billion people
around the world
who have no access to electricity,
And what struck me the most
was finding out that a large proportion
of these people live near the equator,
where sunlight is most abundant.
Coming from a tropical island myself,
the sun has always inspired me.
The amount of heat coming
to my room in the afternoon
is enough to convince me
that the sun is indeed very powerful,
and it made me wonder
why is it that our use of solar energy
today is still very minimal?
To understand how we got here
in the first place,
let’s take a look at a brief history
of how we humans discovered
new sources of energy.
Far before the industrial revolution,
we all started off simply by burning wood
to keep ourselves warm.
In the mid-19th century,
we started hunting for whales in the vast
and empty oceans
for their oils to light illuminant
lamps at home.
We then explored underground
for coal and oil
to power our steam engines and factories.
Recently we started harnessing
nuclear energy
to meet our growing energy consumption.
What’s fascinating is that throughout
these centuries of discoveries,
the sun has always been present.
it has always been right up there,
but we’d rather look underground
and underwater for energy instead.
Well I’m not blaming
the people of the past
because they simply
didn’t have the technology
or understanding on
how to capture the sun’s energy.
But today, in a world far more
technologically advanced than before,
I believe we can do much better.
The economies of the world today
are growing at an exponential rate,
but the nature of that growth itself
is quite unhealthy and unsustainable
due to the amount of pollution we emit.
If we are ever to maintain
this rate of growth,
we need to make a change,
a change towards a cleaner
alternative energy source.
Many countries around the world
are already putting their best efforts
in this transition,
both for the international commitment
to reduce air pollution,
and the positive prospects of solar energy
in their own economies.
Portugal in May 2016 was powered
for four days entirely
from renewable energies that include wind,
hydro, and solar power.
China and India are both planning
to nearly triple their solar capacities
in a few years’ time.
Japan started building
floating solar farms
that plans to power nearly
5000 households by early 2018.
In Germany, 7% of
the total electricity consumption
has already come from solar energy.
You see, these are signs.
These commitments made by these countries
are signs that they have realized
the importance and significance
of solar energy,
and now it’s up to us to decide whether
or not we should welcome this change
and whether or not we should
push it to the next level.
Many people would assume that
a solar dependent future
is too optimistic or is impossible.
Well, I want you all to take
a look at this picture right here.
What do you see?
Many people would say,
"Well, that’s just a rainforest."
What I see is a civilization,
a very prosperous civilization which has
flourished throughout our planet
for a great deal
of our planet’s history
using the energy from the sun.
And if they are capable
of doing such things,
then I believe we could do it too.
In fact, the sun delivers more energy
to our planet in just one hour,
one hour,
than we consume in an entire year.
With our current solar technology,
which has an efficiency of around 20%,
it is estimated that we need an area
around about the size of Spain
to power the entire world.
Now, keep in mind that I said
with our current solar technology.
If that efficiency doubles,
then we willl need half of that area.
Now, the area of Spain
itself may look very big,
but actually, if all the countries
of the world today
devote just 0.4% of their land area
for a solar farm,
that would add up to the size of Spain.
And also keep in mind
that I said land area,
I didn’t even consider
the area of the ocean,
which by the way,
covers 71% of this planet’s surface.
In fact, we could fit in over 700 Spains
on our ocean today,
and we only need the area of
one Spain to power the entire world.
And when I talk about
these facts about areas,
I’m not only talking about those solar
farms with neatly arranged solar panels.
I’m also talking about the actions
of individuals, like you and I,
and how significant an impact we
could make if we all acted collectively.
Take a smartphone as an example.
The average energy needed to charge
a smartphone in a year
is approximately three kilowatt hours.
That is roughly the same energy
that could lift a 1000 ton object,
or around 180 adult elephants
one meter above the ground.
Could you believe that the small phone
you are carrying in your pockets every day
takes up the same energy in a year
that could lift 180 adult elephants
one meter, or around three feet,
above the ground?
Now that is just one phone.
There is an estimated 2.3 billion
smartphone users in the world today,
and in that case, the total energy needed
to charge all the smartphones
in the world per year
would be 7 billion kilowatt hours,
the same energy that could power
an additional 600,000 average
American households.
We could light the homes
of over 600,000 more people
with the energy we use
to charge our smartphones.
If we were instead to charge our phones
with devices like solar-powered
battery packs,
that amount of energy
could actually be saved
to help those who
can’t afford electricity.
If individuals start contributing
in generating just small amounts of energy
to power even the smallest things,
like phones and lamps,
that energy saved would
add up to something much, much bigger.
Fortunately, in today’s modern world,
there are already many inventions
out there that could help us do this.
An example would be
Tesla’s solar roof tiles,
which may cost more than
regular roof tiles at first,
but can actually
be cheaper in the long run
if you consider the cuts
in your electricity bills.
And with the rise of other inventions,
like solar-powered vehicles,
I believe this industry has the potential
to continue growing
and possibly dominate future markets.
Now, let’s not only talk
about the good things.
There are many problems and limitations
to solar energy that we can’t ignore,
but let’s also take a look
at some possible solutions
to overcome them, as well.
The first and most common argument
against solar panels
is that they are too expensive.
Now, there are no disagreements that
I can make here because they are;
they are very expensive.
But I can say the price of solar panels
has been falling drastically
over the past 40 years.
The price of a solar panel
back in the mid-1970s
was around about 80 dollars per watt,
and today that has fallen to less
than a dollar per watt.
That is over 100 times cheaper
than what it was 40 years ago.
And in some countries today,
solar energy is already cheaper
than alternatives, like fossil fuel.
People are no longer using solar energy
because they are cleaner,
but because they are more profitable,
and let’s face it, that’s what most
of us think about.
The second problem with solar energy
is that they are inconsistent.
Solar panels don’t work as well
on cloudy days
and they don’t work at all at night,
the times when most individuals
need energy.
However, with the availability
of batteries,
we can store this energy generated
from sunny days
and use them at times when we need them.
And finally, the last problem associated
with solar energy
is that sunlight is unevenly distributed
across our planet.
Countries in the northern
and southern hemispheres
tend to receive less sunlight
than those in the equator,
and some of those countries may not
be able to rely on solar energy just yet.
Those countries could instead look towards
other forms of renewable energy,
such as bio-fuel, geothermal or wind,
until a possible solution in the future
could be found.
Now, despite all these issues
that I’ve talked about,
we must all be reminded
of a very important fact:
that the world today is slowly
running out of fossil fuel.
Putting the problem of pollution aside,
we must all understand that fossil fuel
cannot keep us running forever.
The fossil fuel that we are using today
have accumulated from the past
millions and millions of centuries,
and we have used up so much
of them in only 250 years.
It is even predicted that we will
completely run out of fossil fuel
by the next 50 to 100 years,
and if we are not seriously committed
on replacing these fossil fuels,
then we and the future generations
may not be able to enjoy the things
that are available to us today.
Especially in a world faced with issues
like global warming and climate change,
solar energy should be met
with more open arms.
And maybe one day, when the whole
world looks up into the sun,
and when those billions
could finally light up their homes,
I can once again look up into
the night sky of Nyepi Day back in Bali,
not scared, but deeply, deeply, satisfied,
knowing that we are, in fact,
the only people in the world
still living in the dark, like cavemen.
Thank you.